so it's that time of the year when they
give out the nobel prizes and the press
release has recently come out for the
nobel prize in physics it's actually
split into two parts half of it goes to
arthur ashken
and the other half goes to gerard maru
and donna strickland and each has an
interesting personal aspect arthur
asking is actually the oldest person
ever to win a nobel prize at 96. wow
exactly yeah pretty impressive and uh
donna strickland
is somewhat depressingly only the third
woman ever to share the nobel prize the
first in 55 years and the other
interesting thing is that the work that
she won the prize for she won when she
was a phd student so this is her
gerald marrow was her supervisor and
this was work she was doing as a phd
student
and traditionally phd students have sort
of been excluded from the nobel prize
famously joslin baldwinell didn't get
the nobel prize for the work so that she
did as a phd student but as supervisor
did for example
clearly the nobel prize committee is
moving with the times a bit it says two
applications of laser physics that they
got the prizes for fortunately a
sufficient laser physics that even an
astronomer can kind of understand it and
actually it's really neat we start with
arthur ashkin he won it for the optical
tweezers and their application the
biological systems so he invented the
thing called optical tweezers so he
discovered a way of using a laser as a
pair of incredibly sensitive tweezers
does that mean the light can
pick things up it can hold them very
very carefully very very delicately and
can feel any kind of tug
so it's a very like a very sensitive way
of measuring when things are being
pulled for example
and it's a it's a really clever piece of
physics that you use to do that what he
was doing is he would take a laser beam
and take a very small glass or plastic
sphere not that much larger than the
wavelengths of light and put it in the
laser beam and it turns out that a
little plastic sphere or glass sphere
will stay in the laser beam when you
place it there and the physics is quite
neat for that so let me show you the
picture of what's going on so here's a
laser beam and the only thing you really
need to know about this laser beam is
that it's brighter in the middle more
intense in the middle and then gets
fainter as you work your way out towards
the edges of the beam thing called a
gaussian beam it just basically means
it's brightest in the middle and here's
our little sphere and the dotted line
here shows the midline so this little
sphere has kind of been displaced
upwards a bit and you can see that what
happens as the laser light interacts
with this little fairly transparent
sphere as it goes through it but it gets
refracted and we've actually talked
about this when we did the physics of
rainbows and those kinds of things where
we talked about light going through
liquid drops in that case but it's the
same story it's just basically the the
little sphere has a different refractive
index so that bends the light as it goes
through this bit of the light gets bent
upwards and the bit that goes the other
side gets bent downwards but because the
light was more intense towards the
middle of the beam more of the light
gets bent upwards and gets dead
downwards light carries momentum with it
and that means the momentum of the light
going upwards is more than the momentum
of the light going downwards in other
words there's a net momentum upwards for
the light but momentum has to be
conserved so if the light's acquiring
momentum upwards that means the little
glass sphere has to be acquiring
momentum downwards so that pushes it
back towards the middle of the beam
conversely if it had been displaced in
the other direction exactly the opposite
occurs more light gets bent downwards
against bend upwards that means there's
more momentum on the light going
downwards that means that the little
sphere has to acquire momentum upwards
so the net effect of this is that the
little sphere always moves back towards
the middle of the beam if it starts to
drift away there's a net kind of
restoring force and in that case it's
very like a little spring balance you
know if you pull it the spring will tug
you back to where you started and if you
squeeze it then it'll push you back it's
the same story and you can use this in
exactly the same way as you use a spring
balance to measure forces you can
actually see how if you apply a force of
that little sphere how far it gets
displaced until those forces balance out
does that mean you can only use these
tweezers with objects that refract light
so the neat thing then that ashkin and
his collaborators went on to do is you
can actually glue the end of a molecule
to one of these little spheres so he did
experiments with things like dna to find
out how stretchy it is by essentially
gluing one end of it to one of these
spheres and seeing how much the the
little sphere was tugged by the dna so
you use the sphere just as something
that you would attach something else to
now there's one further subtlety in this
which is as we said the light carries
momentum some of that light gets
refracted but some of it actually gets
absorbed by the sphere that means that
there's a transfer of momentum from the
light to the sphere so there's a
tendency for the sphere to get pushed
along the beam and of course what we
want here is the little sphere to stay
in the same place so we can do
experiments with it so you need somehow
to stop the sphere moving along the beam
the very early experiments they found a
very simple way of stopping the sphere
moving on the beam which is that if you
do the experiment this way up then the
light's trying to push the sphere up and
gravity is trying to pull the sphere
down and so that actually you can choose
the brightness of your light to exactly
balance it there now it turns out that
doesn't work particularly well because
the thing's a bit unstable and it'll
tend to go drift one way or the other
and so what ashken discovered was a much
subtler way of doing the same thing
instead of having the light just as a
parallel beam as we were showing before
what he actually did was got a very
strong lens like a microscope lens that
means that the light is in a very
convergent beam so the light's actually
converging on the sphere and then you
can see again the light still gets
refracted as it comes through and comes
out the other side but you can see that
the light going out is traveling more
along the beam than the light that was
coming in the light was coming in was
was at a steeper angle so again the
light coming out actually has more
momentum in this direction than the
light coming in because the light coming
in wasn't really traveling in that
direction so much again that means
there's been a change of momentum that
there is now more momentum for the light
traveling along the beam momentum has to
be conserved that means that sort of net
transfer of momentum pushes the sphere
back in the opposite direction so you
use the two properties of the light the
refraction and that conservation of
momentum there which tends to pull the
sphere back towards the lens here and
the light kind of being absorbed by this
via trend push it along those two
effects balance each other out and again
the sphere will stay in a fixed point if
the light isn't hitting or interacting
or physically touching the sphere how is
the message getting to the sphere hey
sphere
you've got to follow the rules here make
sure you move this way out that way how
are the two communicating i mean but it
clearly is interacting with the sphere
right because actually somehow the light
comes in in one direction and comes out
in another direction and so for whatever
the process of interaction between that
electromagnetic wave and the sphere
actually is and in detail it's immensely
complicated
it has to have been interacting for it
to have actually changed its direction
and so in order for momentum to be
conserved in the universe that means
that the sphere needs to be pushed back
in the opposite direction so there is
there is a when light hits it there is
like a physical
reaction like a physical collision there
is a physical yeah exactly i mean you
know this idea of creating solar sails
where you actually have a large light
gathering sail which absorbs sunlight
and that will push the sail along so
this is exactly the same thing that that
interaction with the sphere is pushing
it around is this nobel prize a triumph
of like an incredible idea or what seems
like it may have been some very very
good experiment making
like it seems like it would have been
very hard to engineer and make this i
think it's both actually it was you know
it was a brilliant idea and somebody
actually had the technical skills to
make it work and to think out through
all these details as to how to you know
make it not travel along the beam make
it not move backwards and forwards
and just set the whole system up so it's
a combination of a very clever idea and
then actually having the technical
skills to make it work as well with the
name tweezers i get the impression this
is like a useful tool who uses these
tweezers all sorts of people so ashken's
original work was in biology but
actually i have a much more recent
example so people are actually using
these optical tweezers to try and see
whether newton's laws of gravity are
actually modified on very small scales
it's traditionally very hard to do
gravity experiments on very small scales
because gravity is a very weak force and
if you're doing things on very small
scales kind of by definition you have
quite small masses in order to get them
that close together which means the
effects are pretty small these tweezers
are so incredibly sensitive that they
can actually measure
these gravitational effects
of the in this case what you do is you
create a little cantilever here so just
a little diving platform and then a
little sphere here and you can measure
the gravitational interaction between
these two things and see as you move
this little sphere around by just moving
the laser beam around see how the force
of gravity changes as you move the
sphere closer and further away from the
cantilever to see if newton's laws are
actually obeyed or if there's extra
physics that we need to introduce either
reassuringly or depressingly depending
on your perspective it looks like there
isn't any or at least at the sensitivity
they have been able to do these
measurements but this is the first time
people have really been studying gravity
on these incredibly tiny scales
okay he can keep his nobel prize you're
too kind
so that's one half so then the other
half is gerard murrow and donna
strickland for their method of
generating high intensity ultra short
optical pulses so this is taking laser
light and making very very intense very
short pulses of light
which turns out to be a non-trivial
thing to do because so there are lots of
ways that we have to amplify light it
turns out if you take say a very short
pulse of laser light and you feed it
into an amplifier you can make a
brighter pulse of light if you start
with a very bright pulse of light which
is what you want if you want an
extremely bright passive light when it's
come out the other side of the amplifier
and you just put it into an amplifier
you melt the amplifier because there's
so much intensity of that light already
as it goes in that it's just too much
for an amplifier to handle so there's
kind of a fundamental limit as to how
much you can amplify light in using a
conventional amplifier in that
conventional way so what they did so i
need to reintroduce again another piece
of physics that we've talked about in
the past if you want to make a short
pulse of light you actually need to add
together a whole bunch of different
wavelengths of light this isn't a single
wavelength of light even though it looks
like it is because you can kind of see a
single wave there the only thing that's
really a single wavelength is a sine
wave and this clearly isn't a sine wave
to make something like this you have to
add together a whole bunch of sine waves
of slightly different frequencies and
the shorter the pulse of the light is
the more the range of frequencies you
have to add together so a short pulse of
light actually contains light of lots of
different wavelengths lots of different
colors so and that was the fact that
they exploited in order to actually
amplify a very short pulse of light in a
very clever way here it is schematically
here's our initial pulse of light and we
know we can't feed that straight into
our amplifier because it will melt the
amplifier so what they did is they feed
it into a device that kind of spreads
those different colors out in time the
red light gets to the front and the blue
light gets to the back so basically you
just have a system of gratings or
something which as you pass the light
through the red light gets through first
and the blue light gets through last so
now we spread the pulse out in time then
you feed that into the amplifier and of
course none of it's particularly bright
at this point because we've spread all
that energy out and so we can amplify
that without melting our amplifier then
you feed it into a gizmo which just
reverses that spreading out so we put
everything back together again and you
end up with a whacking great bright
pulse of light it's so elegant it's
really brilliant why do you have to
have this pulse break the pulse apart
and then put it back together why not
put in the constituent parts in the
first place because actually the easiest
part of making those constituent parts
is by starting with a smaller pulse and
splitting it up
you're right in principle you could
create each separately but it would be
incredibly fiddly to do whereas here
it's kind of you're automatically
getting things in the right combination
because you know it it combines to
create a single little pulse and so you
know by the end of it it's going to
combine to create one whacking big pulse
this is a piece of technology that
actually quite a lot of people have
encountered if you've ever had
corrective laser eye surgery the
strength of their lasers they're using
the vaporized bits of your cornea the
way they can actually make the pulses
strong enough to do that is because it
uses this technology the thing that
splits them apart was that like an
awesome piece of technology or was it
just the notion of splitting it apart
that was the clever idea it was the
notion i don't think you know the the
the frequency splitter and frequency
combiners existed before they were just
the people who thought if we do this we
can solve a problem so they just took
sort of more or less off-the-shelf
things and put them together in a way
that no one had thought to put them
together before oh that gives hope for
people like me that i could win
yeah just go through your cupboards and
see if there's anything there you can
stick together to make something no
one's thought of before unfortunately of
all the many ways of sticking things
together you know 99.999 percent of them
are complete rubbish and it's only once
in a while you hit one of these genius
ideas you happy with these this year's
nobel prizes i mean you would have
preferred an astronomer oh no actually i
you know i really like it firstly they
went to interesting people this year
that's a good thing both of these ideas
are so neat i just it's one of those
things the fact that you can explain
them in a five minute video and really
you know
understand what the physics was the fact
that you come away from it thinking well
i could have thought of that
those to my mind are the best kind of
discoveries because yes anyone could
have thought of that but nobody did
until these people came along and were
able to make that leap of doing
something completely different and
that's why i really like this kind of
prize that it's so simple but so because
of that it's so elegant
five minute
video
you all landed it down
hi thanks for watching do check out the
video about the 2018 chemistry nobel
prize over on our sister channel
periodic videos or you can watch past
videos about nobel prizes we've done
lots of them over the years there's a
playlist and i'll include a link on the
screen and down in the video description